-It's been decades since the Land of Wolves had a top hero...
but there was one hope.
-Ha ha! Gotcha, Sensei Garnett!
-Get outta here with that mess, lil [beep].
You ain't no wolf, you barely a dog.
-Shifty!
Run away to Bean Town again, oldhead.
-That ain't trash talk. This is TRASH TALK.
You [beep beep beep] little [beep] [beep].
-Man, you not even supposed to say stuff like that anymore.
-If you not ready to hear that s**t, then you ain't ready for your test.
-YOU AIN'T READY!!!!
-But young Ant would not be deterred...
-Man, I'll show him not ready...
-Superstar. Superstar. Superstar.
-You see once a year, all the top heroes put aside their
differences for a sacred ritual.
-Bring forth the candidate.
-A ritual to see who is worthy to make the leap.
-If you make the leap,
you will get untold riches,
adoring fans, and various vanity projects, such as
a mini golf game show.
-After I made MY leap, people learned how to pronounce my name!
-Mikal, in your last village, you were the third option at best...
but now, Brooklyn thinks they may finally have a hero.
Are you ready...TO TAKE THE LEAP?!
-LEAP. LEAP. LEAP. LEAP. LEAP. LEAP. LEAP. LEAP. LEAP.
♪♪♪ THEME SONG ♪♪♪
-MIKAL'S... BRIDGES!
woah!
-Minnesota has suffered too long without a star...
-Hey...
-I will take the leap.
-You sure, kid? Failure to make the leap would result in falling off.
-I ain't worried.
-Leap! Leap! Leap! Leap! Leap!
-Now or never!
- Leap! Leap! Leap! Leap!
-WHOA!
-I'd like to thank our sponsors, the Way of the Sub,
for catering our event. Please help yourself.
-See, what Ant didn't know
is that the leap tests each hero in their own way.
First, he had to surpass other stars.
Then prove he could carry a team.
-This is a lot easier without Bev.
[Sigh]
-Next, he had to prove he could carry himself...
-Are you gonna stay in Minnesota forever?
-What team are you gonna leave us for?
-Is there any space in your bandwagon?
-Thank goodness Rudy ain't here.
-What’s Sandler like?
-And the media is going to-
-Why did you do the Celtics like that?
get a sound bite,
-What’s your favorite big market?
one way or another.
-Why do you think you’re better than MJ?
-Look, y'all know me.
Y'all know my game. I love doing what I'm doing,
and I love The Land of The Wolf.
Even if it does get a little cold!
-Oh, so charismatic!
-And funny too!
-[Whew]
-Aw...
-But could Ant pass the ultimate test: Become a defender...
-How the hell am I gonna beat that?
-...or at least look like one.
-Remember what I said-
-I ain't taking advice from you. You didn't want to me do this.
-That was a training tactic, b***h
-That's it!
-Get outta here with that weak a** [beep beep beep].
-Aw, here boy.
-Wait, watch out!
-Remember, anything is possible...mothaf***er.
-Imma call you Anthony Edwards Jr.
-And that's the story of how Ant made the leap...
And got that dog in him.
Speaking of dogs and KG...
One day we woke up to a three-legged cocker spaniel
and we did NOT know where it came from.
-So KG was like, “I'm about to play this dog one on one.”
-Man, who knew Jeff Teague was such a good storyteller?
But I said “KG, its got 3 legs, what the hell?”
[chuckle] and he said, “man shut the f**k up.”